[Music]
my name is Nelson neo I'm the founder of
shield women's self-defense these are
some simple defense moves for common
assault for women
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] off
[Music]
the main thing to remember is to be
aware of your surroundings always always
use your core so you're not flailing
around with your upper body also when
you have someone behind you strike the
groin first grabbing grabbing the face
is really good you just hold on to the
face boom you just grab on and push it
back on someone pointing a gun at you
one if you can run you run you run zig
zag and screaming
the myth that if women fight back the
guy's gonna get angrier and woman's
gonna get hurt that's only through if
you hit him a few times and look and
he's gonna come at you differently so
the first hit me throw you you need to
be fully committed and become the
aggressor
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes you're simply overpowered when
you're overpowered just realize for a
second and fake compliance is key say
okay okay okay
I'll do whatever you want please don't
hurt me get him to relax first and then
you fight the number there's no
opportunity women if any size can do
this now unless you know what to do and
you know how to use leverage
[Music]